what's going on reject nation of Greg
Alba hi I'm John Humphrey we are going
to watch today a patron video request
from Jason Dolan
it's called Myles Fisher this must be
the place interesting I heard is like an
American Psycho music video or something
Jason Dolan is a hard-working
screenwriter a talent and a guy who is
actually just a really good friend of
mine you know I really love this guy a
lot he occasionally talked a couple
times a week he got this camera for us
man he's just one of the best dudes in
the world I love the [ __ ] out of him
Jason if you're watching I rub your head
while I'm doing stuff to your pet hey
anyway let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
this is neat oh that's impressive your
finger push-ups
[Music]
this dude just looks so much like him
out of here it's got the cold
[Music]
[Music]
that isn't like candy
[Music]
ha ha I would do that
you've got
I think I have that oh yeah I just
learned the name of that too
[Music]
it's like a christian bale out of Babe
Ruth Tom Cruise
[Music]
the facial expression so undeniably
similar that's crazy
do you like miles Fisher his latest EP
marks a new this is his take on David
Burns this must be the place
a great
Birdman
is where I want to be the other girl
looks nothing like that
[Music]
what are you doing evil laugh what you
clean your vagina
we have the exact what is it
[Music]
kind of [ __ ] up a little bit for the
room whoa that's how you get friendly
hey sup yellow dollars
[Music]
[Music]
that that may sensor yeah can't show too
much blood
[Music]
nice
that's impressive ass [ __ ] right there
man I haven't heard the David Byrne song
and so long I act don't have a good
frame of reference for miles Fisher is
that wow that's just him no makeup
prosthetics Angie I ever seen miles
Fisher before and he does look so much
like Christian Bale that is crazy
yeah I mean it's like of course he does
the mannerisms to help out he's got that
smile yeah yeah it's just even like the
way I browse everything he does pretty
uncanny stuff and as terms of like a
tribute music video and also semi spoof
that's some really impressive stuff
right there I've must have been the best
thing ever to help recreate an add-on to
it I'm glad you got to do your sex scene
that was the one spot you were like no
we really gotta go all out hey I
appreciate you two for being a bit
progressive and showing more sex than
you chose to show violence
yeah like fixing the problem little by
little and America were better with the
blood that we are with the nudity though
we do get on fix that you're gonna do an
American Psycho thing you should have
killed it to the blood less on the
sexual aspect of it too we don't do that
here except we do and it's all the time
there's a weird charm to this because
it's obviously nowhere near the budget
quality of the actual film but at the
same time you're like yeah with the
resources that you had on hand I love
how he's the only one that looks like
Christian Bale but everyone else doesn't
look at all like the people they're
portrayed there's a blonde girl
and there's brunette chick and then
there's a guy who looks nothing like
Jared Leto and he
wait that wasn't him he didn't show up
to to feature 30 seconds to Peters
crossover for your next EP maybe do
mericans I go to the beloved classic
Starling Mila Kunis and Shatner that was
a great one it's a great one yeah it
makes me wonder why this movie had such
an impact wasn't like a huge box-office
hit but it's made such a crazy impact
over time and like to go all out and do
a music video like this is just like
what exactly is what inspired you we
just love the movie that beloved
American Psycho this much and I really
love the movie too but it is one of
those things where Christian Bale is not
in it I don't think that's probably a
key element of that of why that movie is
so beloved and we see this with so many
films that get read reg Dover the time
is if you don't have the people who made
it what it was a lot of times you don't
have that thing and Christian Bale is so
much of what makes that movie what it is
you know especially since they changed
things from the book you know to it's
like it's a different take and he really
brings it to life that's true I mean I
guess the next thing this guy has to do
is a Mission Impossible theme song music
video yeah yeah yeah brace your crews
embrace the crew side because you do
look a lot like Tom Cruise as well so
you do a little hybrid and then you can
do a Superman music video cuz you kind
of got the Chris Reeve Brandon and Ralph
thing going do like a Superman thing
next because you know DC is doing well
you could even catapult yourself into
Henry cavils place when they eventually
do a second Superman because they're
firing him but they're not firing him he
also looks like Freddie Highmore a
little bit you know why psycho he's he's
a white guy oh you got the dark skin
piercing eyebrows in how you are you're
that one not the dark skin all the skin
yeah you're black white guy yeah a man
but from a quick research it looks like
this guy is also a working
actor it would appear I mean he
certainly looked profession camera yeah
cuz I was gonna say for like a musician
like this is pretty impressive like
impersonation skills he's got down
that's the key to his music actuals
every song has a carrot wait a minute I
think he has a video on here stop I can
eat planets this guy does embrace the
people who looks like that's gay that's
making lemons out of lemonade you know
flip that I guess I've gotta start doing
something where I look like the Indian
guy from inception yeah and and cliff
Curtis
yeah and I'll probably have a career
I'll be known for looking like those
ethnically ambiguous guys except one
definitely looks Indian ok Myles
Fisher's gonna be my new obsession
that's what's happening right now you're
my new obsession yeah they should make
final destination music video - it's
Halloween time man you gotta get on
fishing yeah all right well hey Myles
Fisher I'm glad to finally know who you
are buddy you are Tom Cruise and
Christian Bale impersonator yeah Tom
Cruise it's like it was one thing to
just see him I mean like I think if
you're a white guy it's probably pretty
easy to do the American Psycho voice did
you know I'm utterly insane oh yeah all
you gotta do is do everyone's impression
of a white guy literally I'm Patrick
Bateman so it was one thing like seeing
how he looks like him and it's probably
easier for him to mirror the body
language and the facial expressions but
then to hear him do that that funny bit
about you know miles fish this guy's
obviously a multi-talent is that he is
that his version of that song or
something that's my understanding of it
yes he did a new take on this must be
the place that's awesome yeah all right
well hey guys you should subscribe to
miles Fisher's YouTube channel because
that's clearly where his main focus is
at and you could recordings in looking
at you know Saved by the Bell spoof know
there's Helles
oh man all right well subscribe to the
regeneration click that notification
bell and check I saw patron we got TV
show reactions and John does music video
coverage over there as well as weekly
Q&A Jim the two of us see you soon